[موسيقى]
ليندا يا كارينو الرئيس التنفيذي الجديد
لموقع تويتر
ستتولى مهامها الجديده خلال سته اسابيع
ثلاثه عقود قضتها بمجال الاعلان والتسويق
تشغل حاليا منصب رئيس مجلس اداره
الاعلانات والشراكات العالميه في ام بي سي
تشرف على الفي عامل وحققت معهم 100 مليار
دولار من مبيعات الاعلانات
عام 2018 عينها ترامب لتخدم بمجلسه للياقه
الرياضيه والتغذيه لعامين
عام 2021 شراكه مع اداره بايدن لانشاء
حمله لقاح ضد كورونا
ابريل 2022 ماسك وياكارينو
ظهر معا تحت عنوان من المحادثه للشراكه
اختيار يا كريم يؤشر لتغيير بالمنصه قد
يريح المعلمين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات